one woman passed away another is behind
bars facing murder and arson charges
after a mobile home burst into flames
police say 37-year-old tiffany willis
started the fire at the echo park mobile
home yesterday afternoon that's off
mojave near charleston and joe mohler
live outside of the clark county
detention center where willis is right
now with what a neighbor says happened
joe
tiffany willis is behind bars here while
that other woman was transported to the
hospital she passed away due to the
burns on her body we did speak to a
neighbor who lives just next door he was
worried something like this could happen
i've been here 20 years from hawaii mike
wilcox says he is now forced to find a
new place to live the fire was burned so
you know the heat of course is going to
melt everything and that's how it
started his home was damaged after the
mobile home next door went up in flames
wednesday these people shouldn't have
been here from the beginning the blaze
took one woman's life thursday tiffany
willis appeared in front of a judge
you're being detained at this time with
no bail she was arrested for allegedly
starting the fire wilcox says the
argument was over infidelity he was
fooling around with another girl in the
back and where this whole thing started
on the mattress whatever in the back and
she went over there and she burned the
stuff and she started the fire he says
these additional areas on the side of
the mobile home had people living in it
totally illegal and we've been like i
said we've been complaining about this
for how long and nobody did anything he
says multiple mobile homes are boarded
up because homeless frequent the area my
wife was saying eventually this would
happen one day and look it did it
happened last night
back out here live we did reach out to
the county to see if there was any
reports regarding this they said they
didn't have any for that specific site
that specific mobile home that is and we
tried reaching out to the company that
oversees echo park mobile home park but
we have yet to hear back willis is due
back in court next wednesday no bail was
set reporting live in downtown las vegas
joe mohler live local now joe